The joe rogan experience.
What,
what happens is,
is that with these careers is,
um,
Gail again,
you know,
a year after Gilligan's
island goes off the air goes,
uh,
Bob Denver goes,
fuck this,
I'm not wearing that stupid white hat.
And the red crew neck sweater thing,
the white pants like bull shit.
And then he does about 10
years of this is bullshit.
And then he does about five
years of soul searching.
And then at some point he opens the
closet and grabs that hat and going down,
open that fucking boat show in Long Beach
and walk out of here with nine grand.
And then it starts and then it
starts to wax the stylish about it.
So I think,
uh,
the dice man put down the pack of
cigarettes in the leather vest and said,
uh,
I'm going to do some other things and
at a certain point realize ain't paying
the bills doing it.
Do you remember when he had a sitcom?
He went,
he went clean for,
he had a sitcom on CBS and it was called,
bless this house or something like that,
wasn't it called?
That was like when kiss went on mass and
it was with the woman from raging bull.
Yeah.
What the fuck is common?
Rossby
I mean salad,
the fuck was her name because she was
super hot and then she got Chubby as fuck.
Yes.
Oh,
Deann,
no,
not the Angelo.
Um,
fuck is her name.
Cathy Moriarty and Moriarty's
Mr. Hot as fuck.
And then you know,
much like all of us,
she fell upon us all the
daisy Duke girl added Bach,
sorry to comic book convention.
It was the saddest thing you will ever
see her sitting there with her little
shorts,
but they weren't as
sharp as they used to be.
And she just,
just sitting there,
no one talking to her.
No one even knowing that
she's sitting there,
I just walk up and I'm like,
this is daisy Duke right here.
She goes and I'm like,
Oh,
you're signing autographs.
She goes,
$25 I'm like,
oh no.
And I was like,
can I take a picture?
And she goes,
yeah,
that's $10 I'm like,
no,
it's the notes with my camera.
And she goes,
yeah,
it's $10.
But it was the saddest thing ever.
I'm like,
no thank you.
And I just walked away.
And this little daisy Duke just sit
in the corner by herself sitting at a
folding chair.
Can I tell you something?
That's Saturn,
uh,
moments ago when Joe was like,
you know,
what's the name of that
sir?
And they put the fatwa on the guy.
Remember Andy wrote Satanic Verses.
Remember that?
What was the name of that guy?
And I'm like,
yeah,
you know that author,
remember he had to,
he had to hide because they'd
put a hit on him and Cat Stevens,
uh,
you know,
gave a two thumbs up and
what's the name of that author?
And I'm like,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I damn couldn't tell you,
but when you're like,
um,
I saw it.
Daisy Duke,
Catherine Bach,
fucking sad.
Well,
we were a kid.
She was
sad that,
that's where my knowledge base.
Not that old though.
How old is she?
She,
she looks probably about 50.
So it's just the booze is,
it looked just like sadness,
sadness,
booze or drugs.
It's a,
it's amazing how the booze really jacks.
Yeah,
it was a little freckles
weren't there as much anymore.
She's done.
But then you look at like,
um,
Christie Brinkley
is still hot as fuck.
Well something or another,
she's keeping it together and she's
like 53 I have this fun imaginary game.
No,
I like to play when I get stone,
which is a sort of the acts,
it's like it's,
it's a cross.
Okay.
And let's say when you
were in junior high,
let's say you're,
let's say you're in the seventh grade
for the sake argument and a dukes of
hazard is hitting its prime,
the good old boy and a blown up down
house with the crossbow and whatnot.
And you're,
you're just sitting there and you're
seeing an episode that has Catherine Bach
tight daisy dukes,
and she does that thing where she leans
over the open hood and the steam comes
out and everything.
And now there you are little pecker wood,
New Jersey in seventh grade and you're,
now you're at the bottom of each acts.
You couldn't get further away.
There's,
it's not like you stole
a bus ticket to La.
You could fuck Catherine Bach.
No Way.
You're a million miles away.
So true.
Okay.
But now,
now you start heading up the legs
of the acts and just a good old.
Now we move on.
10 years.
Joseph,
standup comedian,
getting started,
having a little success,
making a little money,
grown into his body and become
sexual sexually charged.
He's 23,
2123 years of age now.
A dukes of hazards been off the air,
you know,
uh,
15 years.
Yeah,
they've been off.
Well,
no,
I'm saying at this point,
yeah.
Okay.
Let's say it's been off 10 years,
10 years,
but she's still,
she's 36.
They'll look looking pretty tight.
You know,
whatever looking at,
but Joe's not looking too bad either.
And Joe starting to do a little standup,
whatever.
At what point,
Joe,
at what point do you cross her?
Like at a certain point,
I mean,
when you're in the seventh grade,
you were sold your fucking soul and killed
your step mom to get one liquor that
pussy.
Right.
But now,
but now,
but if I asked you repulsive
if I asked you this second.
Yeah.
Well then obviously you guys crossed.
Yes.
What Year did you cross?
That's,
that's my game.
And then,
but and then there's something like,
Ooh,
you haven't crossed Christie Brinkley yet,
or maybe you're meeting maybe
about nine months away from,
from just hitting right in the middle.
If Chritton and Christie
Brinkley's still above me.
She's got me.
Yeah,
she's shy,
but maybe she's still hot and she's
53 you know she's like 57 oh Jesus.
That's my point.
She's going to be 60 maybe I,
maybe I crossed her at
57 but she looks great.
Maybe.
Maybe she does it with TV.
You can never really tell.
I'll have to ask Christine.
We'll,
we'll see what we can agree
to be an awesome coach.
The Catherine Bach thing,
it all depends on how much
Catherine Bach took care of herself,
whether or not she was
still sharing movies.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
There's,
there's some women that even though
they've kind of deteriorated,
there's still have a level
of respect when news radio,
she's been off TV for 14 years.
You know what saying once
fear factor happened,
I had her mine,
she was mine when I was hosting,
if I wanted to get Katherine,
I don't work out some
sort of bracket list,
you know what I mean?
We're just really,
you could find all the chicks you wanted
to fuck when you were in the eighth
grade and see when you cross that
there is nothing stranger than watching
a woman go from being beautiful and
having ultimate power.
A really super hot chick,
super hot.
21 year old chick has almost,
it's almost voodoo.
You know,
like their body and the
way they move and like toy,
they smell and if they like you and if
they're smart too and if you're not sure
if you can get them,
God damn,
it's almost fucking viewed.
It's ultimate power.
It's super celebrity power.
The reason why celebrities get so
ridiculously fucked up trumps everything.
The reason why celebrities gets so
ridiculously big headed and she goes,
everywhere you go,
people are kissing your ass.
Everywhere you go,
people are,
here's you know,
free bottle service.
Here's a limousine for free,
please eat at my restaurant.
You're amazing.
You've changed my life and you start
thinking that will start the shot.
That's an awesome thought,
Mr Rob.
But girls from the moment
they're little from the moment.
They literally are so cute.
You're so beautiful.
And then they're in high school.
Then it becomes currency.
It becomes the thing that defines them
and then it goes away and it goes away
slowly.
It goes away.
Weird when they start looking
like that rough bar girl,
you know,
like still hot but in her
thirties but you know,
he could see her at a cigarette and maybe
I'd get a couple of shots of Jack in
you and let's just go fucking the woods.
You know,
just some crazy bitch.
It's just,
she's not the 21 year old grows that
cheerleader who it was impossible to get.
Now she's just wild bitch.
He's just,
yeah,
you feel forced.
You're trying to pay her bills.
She had been divorced,
you know,
and then eventually they become monsters.
They become this weird thing,
especially if they get,
they go down the surgery route,
please ladies,
please just get old.
Don't go crazy,
don't fuck with your lips in your neck
and all that nutty shit does not make you
look better.
It makes you look different and that
different is not a good different,
it's a weird monster.
Different,
well also you
guys are going through historically a
bad phase because your mother didn't have
to worry about plastic surgery because
it didn't really exist and your daughter
won't really have to worry about it
because they'll have perfected it.
You even are,
you are in network engineering.
Yeah.
You're in the experimental
phase and it ain't working out.
It's Sorta like CGI that it's a bad
generation because our folks were watching
movies that every stunt
was an actual stunt,
just done by duty,
didn't give a shit.
And our kids enjoy CGI.
That works so effectively.
You can't tell.
We went through a whole phase where we
had to watch shitty movies with really
bad effects because they were perfecting
it on our watch and we were sitting in
the theater will now we're in the theater
of plastic surgery and all you women,
it's accent.
You're essentially,
it's 50 year experimental
phase while they're working
on it and you're looking like,
shit.
Yeah,
you're a fucking human being.